yeah i mean i would think you know the
age of the was the food network you know
is like kind of you know goes defiance
of this like traditional apprenticeship
program that that I went through and
that it seems to me more chefs more
cooks today could really benefit from
yes so the answer is unqualified I think
you know an apprenticeship program the
kind that I went through which was you
know in France and and and kind of
hardcore is is an important maturation
process hardcore just because back then
you know there weren't the rules there
are today on the French kitchens and he
owes it was there are mean places to
work and they didn't like Americans I
mean like Americans now but they didn't
like Americans been and you know and and
and the French kitchen of the the
history the the social dynamic that's
involved in in the gastronomical
services wherever you are but especially
in the kitchen is intense and takes a
lot of discipline and a lot of technique
and then what not and that's a great
place to learn Spain today is a big one
for cooks to go to and you get the same
sort of inculcation in history and of
discipline so yeah I think it's really
important
Oh